let's talk a little bit about
crystalline and amorphous polymers now
in previous videos we talked about
crystalline versus amorphous solids
crystalline solids have a very regular
pattern maybe they look something like
this if you imagine the particles each
of these circles being an atom an ion or
molecule
while in an amorphous solid it's a
little bit more irregular it's still
solid so these things aren't moving past
each other like they would in a liquid
but it is an irregular pattern so this
is crystalline and this is amorphous
solids generally now the focus of this
video is to talk about crystalline and
amorphous solids made from polymers
polymers can actually exist in a
spectrum someplace between being
crystalline and being amorphous so just
as a review what is a polymer well a
polymer is a molecule that's made up of
repeated subunits so you have a subunit
and then it's bonded to another unit and
another unit and it makes these
molecules which on a molecular scale are
long
made up of these repeating units and so
i can represent them if i were to zoom
out a little bit is kind of a string
like thing but just remember these are
made up
by these repeating units
now in previous videos we talked about
how polymers can be amorphous because
these long strings of these repeating
units can get all intertwined like this
and form this messy ball and we talked
about things like elastomers where
natural rubber is like this where you
can pull on it and as long as you don't
pull too much it'll get back to this
form
but it turns out that these polymers can
also align to various degrees and become
a little bit more crystalline for
example even with rubber if you were to
pull on it it's possible that the
individual chains get a little bit more
aligned and then the intermolecular
forces between them are going to be a
little bit stronger
because they are a little bit more
aligned and so this form would be more
crystalline not perfectly crystalline
but more crystalline when you have this
alignment
and to just see examples of different
polymers that sit on that spectrum let
me draw a spectrum right over here
where at
this end we have something that is very
amorphous
and at this end we have something that
is very
crystalline
we can see examples from our everyday
life
if we focus on plastics for example
polystyrene which you might be familiar
as foam packaging right over here this
is reasonably amorphous i'm not going to
go into the exact numbers but let's say
we could put it right over here so this
is made up of polymers repeating units
but they're going to be fairly
disordered and something like that and
that's what gives it kind of its
softness that's why it's good as a
packaging material it can absorb jolt
now if we go a little bit further down
the spectrum something that is still
amorphous but has more of a crystalline
nature you can look at things like
plastic water bottles often known as
p-e-t bottles p-e-t stands for
polyethylene
phthalate anything like polystyrene
polyethylene the fact that they start
with the words poly is the clue that
these are polymers polystyrene is made
up by a bunch of styrenes in a chain
polyethylene is made up by a bunch of
ethylenes in a chain and so polyethylene
depending on which version of you look
at it it's some place between amorphous
and crystalline for example it might be
some place over here and if you want to
do further research on it you can
actually look up how crystalline
something is the degree of crystallinity
and you'll see numbers like 30 percent
or 40 crystallinity and if you want to
look at especially plastic polymers that
are even more crystalline you can look
at something like kevlar and kevlar
depends on the kevlar you are looking at
it can be someplace in this range here
i'll just put the kevlar
right over there and if you don't know
what kevlar is kevlar is used for making
things like bulletproof vests
and so the degree of crystallinity and
it's not just the degree of
crystallinity but the degree of
crystallinity is how aligned these
things are kevlar the polymers are very
very aligned with each other and so
you're able to have these intermolecular
forces get reasonably strong and that's
why it is good at stopping bullets while
you would never want packaging foam to
stop a bullet for you but these are all
polymers